While we are in the midst of our New Year's resolutions,
which usually means drinking less and working out more,
maybe eating a tad healthier,
I wanted to send this reminder to whoever might need it.
Skinny does not equal healthy.
You see, about 4 5 years back,
pre COVID, of course,
I was in the best shape of my life.
I was working out regularly.
I was the thinnest I'd ever been.
I was the most fit I'd ever been.
Here's a little reference.
I was a certifiable gym rat at this point.
I'm currently not in that good of a shape.
Some of my clothes don't fit very well.
I have since had a third baby,
and I have some well earned weight gain
after eating and drinking everything in sight
for the past six months.
So does that bother me? A bit? Yeah.
Will I be focusing on fitness in the New Year? Yes,
but my fitness goals will not be aesthetic.
I want to increase in stamina,
strength, flexibility,
balance, and endurance.
Because when I was that fit,
eating clean,
obsessing over workout,
pretty much orthorexic,
my period stopped for four months
and my immune system crashed.
Looks can be deceiving.